>>> UKRAINE'S SOUTH IS LIGHTING
UP.
RUSSIA JUST BOMBED ANOTHER KEY
PORT ON THE BLACK SEA.
THIS TIME IN MYCOLAVE.
THE ATTACKS STARTING JUST AFTER
RUSSIA SIGNED A DEAL PROMISING
TO ALLOW UKRAINIAN SHIPS AT
THOSE PORTS TO TRANSPORT GRAIN
SAFELY.
NOW, UKRAINE AND RUSSIA ARE
BRACING FOR A MASSIVE LAND
FIGHT, AS RUSSIA GEARS UP TO
DEPLOY MORE TROOPS TO THE CITIES
IT ONCE EASILY OCCUPIED.
IVAN WATSON HAS BEEN TRAVELING
THE SOUTHERN FRONT FOR WEEKS.
>> SCENES FROM UKRAINE'S
SOUTHERN FRONT DURING THE FIRST
MONTHS OF THE WAR.
FOOTAGE SHARES EXCLUSIVELY WITH
CNN SHOWS UKRAINIAN SENIOR
LIEUTENANT HIDING IN SHELL
CRATERS.
FLYING A DRONE TO CALL IN
ARTILLERY STRIKES ON RUSSIAN
POSITIONS.
BUT THE TEAM OF SPOTTERS ALSO
NARROWLY ESCAPES LONG RANGE FIRE
FROM THE RUSSIAN MILITARY.
MONTHS AFTER FILMING THESE
VIDEOS, HE IS STILL FIGHTING ON
THE SOUTHERN FRONT.
WERE THE RUSSIANS IN THIS
VILLAGE BEFORE?
>> YEAH.
>> THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY IS
FIGHTING TO CLAW BACK TERRITORY.
>> IT'S VERY SLOW, THE PROCESS
TO TAKE BACK ALL OF OUR
TERRITORIES.
BUT STEP BY STEP AND WITH THE
HELP OF THE WESTERN GUNS AND SO
ON, ARTILLERY SYSTEMS, WE DO IT.
>> THIS MONTH MY TEAM AND I
TRAVELED THE LENGTH OF THE
SOUTHERN FRONT FROM THE CRITICAL
PORT OF ODESA TO THE EDGE OF THE
DONBAS REGION.
I SPOKE TO PEOPLE WILLING TO
RISK THEIR LIVES AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN WAR MACHINE.
IN THE CITY, UKRAINIAN FORCES
STORM A BUILDING.
IT'S ACTUALLY A TRAINING
EXERCISE TO PREPARE THESE MEN
FOR ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
FORMS OF MODERN WARFARE, URBAN
COMBAT.
THE COMMANDER HERE WAS GRAVELY
WOUNDED, PUSHING RUSSIAN BACKED
SEPARATISTS OUT OF CITIES IN THE
EASTERN DONBAS REGION IN 2014.
WE HAVE A DUTY TO LIBERATE OUR
TERRITORIES, HE SAYS.
THIS IS OUR LAND, AND WE WILL
NOT GIVE IT TO ANYONE.
THAT CONFIDENCE SHARED BY A
REGIMENT OF FRONT LINE TROOPS IN
EASTERN UKRAINE.
THEY SHOW OFF RECENTLY ARRIVED
BRITISH MADE LAND ROVERS, AND
THIS ARMORED PERSONNEL CARRIER.
>> I JUST NOTICED SOMETHING.
TAKE A LOOK OVER HERE.
AT THIS TIRE.
MADE IN RUSSIA.
THIS WAS RUSSIAN.
>> IT WAS RUSSIAN CAR.
BUT OUR SOLDIERS FIGHT HIM AND
TAKE THIS CAR.
>> YOU CAPTURED IT.
>> BUT THE WAR IS TAKING A
DREADFUL TOLL HERE.
DAY AND NIGHT, RUSSIAN ROCKETS,
S-300 SURFACE TO AIR MISSILES,
REPURCHASED TO STRIKE GROUND
TARGETS, POUND MYCOLAVE, AND
MORE APPEAR TO BE ON THE WAY.
THEY SHARE THIS EXCLUSIVE
FOOTAGE TAKEN DAYS AGO, SHOWING
THE ARRIVAL OF MISSILES FROM THE
KHERSON REGION.
LATER CONFIRMED BY THESE
SATELLITE IMAGES.
BUT WITH THE HELP OF U.S. LONG
RANGE ROCKETS KNOWN AS HIMARS,
UKRAINE HAS BEEN TARGETING
RUSSIAN AMMO DEPOTS.
THE SENIOR LIEUTENANT SAID HE
NOTICED A DIFFERENCE ON THE
FRONT LINES.
>> WE HAD ABOUT TWO, THREE WEEKS
WHERE THEY HAVEN'T ENOUGH
AMMUNITION TO FIGHT US.
>> STILL, HE PREDICTS IT WILL
TAKE A LONG TIME FOR UKRAINE TO
WIN THE WAR IN THE SOUTH.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT WE WILL WIN
UNTIL THE END OF THIS YEAR.
MAYBE UNTIL THE END OF NEXT
YEAR.
>> JAKE, PART OF THE UKRAINIAN
STRATEGY IS ALSO TO TARGET
RUSSIAN SUPPLY LINES.
SO THEY HAVE BEEN USING THE LONG
RANGE ROCKETS TO HIT BRIDGES
THAT THE RUSSIANS RELY ON TO GET
FROM RUSSIAN CONTROLLED CRIMEA
TO THESE SOUTHERN REGIONS IN THE
SOUTH OF UKRAINE THAT THEY HAVE
MORE RECENTLY OCCUPIED.
THREE OF THOSE BRIDGES HAVE BEEN
HIT BY THESE ROCKETS IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
ALL OF THIS INTENDED TO TRY TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE RUSSIANS